[Musique]
victor vladimir veilleurs bonjour
bonjour monsieur livory bonjour aux
auditeurs de marque la première
singulièrement pilotis néo pilotait
alors vous mener la liste unités
pilotine vous êtes sortis en troisième
position lors du premier tour des
municipales à rivière-pilote avec 23%
des suffrages exprimés vous avez réalisé
9 115 x comment analysez vous ce premier
tour je suis peut-être un candidat de
dernière minute qui avait un problème de
leadership entre deux candidats arrivés
à pilotes notamment du mime la
population a fait son choix
donc je me retrouve qualifiée pour le
deuxième tour et je remercie les 915
piloter que se sont exprimés sur mon nom
et je remarque aussi que le maire
sortant avec 53 % de suffrages exprimés
a perdu 64 % de 63% de son électorat
donc pratiquement 2400 voie entre 2014
et 2020
donc il ya une défiance de la population
envers le maire son temps pour vous ce
premier tour là est ce que ce premier
tour a été marqué aussi par la copie de
il y a plein de facteurs qui ont fait
qu'on a à rivière-pilote 63 %
d'abstention ce qui n'était du jamais vu
jamais vu et bien sûr le coc vite 19 la
crise sanitaire à sa part à jouer
là-dedans il ya aussi la dispersion des
voix du mime parce qu'il ya eu pléthore
de candidats du même parti à ma
connaissance il n'y avait que deux
candidats qui se revendique admin ben
monsieur marc en est quand même
président du cap et du de rivière-pilote
le capi ça me dit quelque chose que
j'aime bien sûr puisque j'y suis donc à
berre on peut considérer que le premier
tout était une espèce de primaire pour
les deux candidats du mime qui avait
essayé la population a fait son choix
est ce qu'elle fait de marie-jeanne fait
toujours recette mobilise toujours
autant arriver à pilotes parce que il
nous soutient et vite en troisième
position on trouve sa première
présentation 915 voix c'est déjà très
bien et on a encore une réserve de voix
qui non négligeable mais je peux vous
dire qu alfred marie jeanne à des voix
sur chez l'ensemble des autres candidats
du premier tour sur les cinq candidats
du premier tour
donc je pense qu'un feu de paille j'en
fais encore cet avis aux pilotes
d'accord edouard marron justement n'en
parlait qui appelle à voter pour le
maire sortant
qu'est ce que ça vous monsieur théodose
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
son communiqué pose question
premièrement pourquoi il l'a fait en
tant que président du cap et est pas
tant que tête de liste mais en tout cas
je ne vais pas m'étendre sur ce
communiqué je vous invite ge avec la
presse à venir au restaurant le cabanon
mercredi soir vie au pilote
le président du comité de soutien de la
liste des doigts marrant et
vice-président du cap et vous apporter
un certain nombre d'éclaircissements sur
ce communiqué pour vous lis pas claire
ce communiqué la pirogue clairement
avoue-t-elle pourra soutenir remonter au
2 caps elle n'a pas autorité à désigner
le candidat pour lequel on doit voter
c'est le cap et est une instance de mime
un organe du mime et c'est le même qui
doit décider
alors si vous êtes élu maire de rivière
pilote
quelle sera la première action que vous
allez mettre en place en fait on a tiré
les leçons de la crise sanitaire est
notre priorité sur les deux trois
premières années à venir mettre un grand
coup de volant sur l'action sociale le
soutien l'accompagnement des entreprises
le soutien l'accompagnement des
associations et le soutien scolaire on
débloquera un million 5 2 euros sur deux
ans et plus on verra en fonction de
l'évaluation boudé ces deux premières
années s'il faut encore continuer mais
le maire de rivière pilote que je serai
sera à côté de sa population
donc cinq cent mille euros pour l'action
sociale trois cent mille pour les
entreprises et l'association 400 milles
pour le soutien scolaire ces enfants qui
n'ont pas été en classe depuis le mois
de janvier quasiment et qui ont besoin
d'être soutenues notamment pendant les
grandes vacances scolaires et tout le
long de l'année scolaire
et face aux intempéries vous avez l'idée
face à la mise on parle beaucoup de mise
hors d'eau du bourg notamment des
rivières pilotes vous avez une idée vous
avez une vision des choses sur ça j'ai
aussi déjà exprimé là-dessus au premier
tour oui donc on ne peut pas réduire
rivière-pilote hobo et assaisonnements
inondations viable aux très riches de
beaucoup d'autres choses mais en tout
cas sur les inondations du beau il faut
que les véritables responsables que sont
l'espace sud et l'état prennent leur
responsabilité dans cette histoire mais
nous avons une vision aussi du
développement de la ville d'abyei parce
que l'heure du développement économique
est arrivée à la ville pour la ville de
rivière-pilote il faut éclater le bourg
notamment ses il faut étendre le bout
vers la n5 vers le rond-point de
poiriers et aménager des zones
économiques
tout le long de cette départementale
commerciale et artisanale
victor vladimir d'ailleurs je vous
remercie c'est moi qui vous remercie
[Musique]